hey it's tom from inspiration metalworks
and in this week's video we're going to
go over
startup procedures and getting set up to
actually run apart on the hercomill
okay for a little background uh i have
had a few folks um especially those who
are new to herco
ask uh how these things run how they
work what the control is like um how you
actually make parts on them and yet to
be honest it's different than other
machines that i've run in some ways and
in other ways it's just like any machine
right there's a startup procedure that
you're going to go through
there's setting work coordinate systems
things like that right
your loading programs
uh there are some things that are
peculiar to the herco uh there are some
things that are unique to the herco that
i think are very um beneficial but uh
it's really not that complicated so
let's get started i don't know if i'm
gonna break this up into multiple videos
or just do one long video it may start
out as one long video and get broken up
i don't know yet uh but um
let's go ahead with our normal stuff i
don't know if you can pick it up on the
microphone or not in the background air
compressor is already running so we're
going to walk around to the back of the
machine
and turn it on
and
we'll get things kicked off so let's go
do that all right so we've walked around
the back of the machine here sorry the
mess it's kind of crazy right now but
anyways when you look up you'll see the
power switch this right here so power's
already on at the breaker so all we'd
have to do
flip that guy up
you've turned on power to the machine
you can hear it kicking off
and we'll get started okay so boot
process
takes a few minutes um
it is not like a fanuc control that just
fires right up and goes um you know it
is a windows based system so you can
actually interact with it if you need to
there's some some menus you can get into
and things like that but for the most
part i never touched that um
i did go in to enable mt connect and
things like that but uh
i
you know
it's really pretty
hands off once once it's set up you
don't have to mess with it too much so
i'll bring you back uh it's not worth
keeping the video running uh for this
and when we're ready to go to the next
step okay
the uh
uh controls booted up um
and guys i'm not working off script i'm
just
you know showing you how i do this every
day
um right now i'll be a little warning
here and you notice i've got the
optional second panel here it is kind of
nice because it lets me bring up
extended dro information
there's some controls over here
uh it does have graphics in here it'll
show you what you're working on you can
do previews all sorts of things right
from the screen
so
if you have the option to have that
second
second screen installed i i highly
recommend it i think it's it's great but
basically the hercule's going to walk
you through what you need to do
it tells you press manual mode power and
cycle start to restore power
so your machine modes are down here
right
um
i think you guys can see
see that i might let me tilt this down
just a little bit so you can see
a little bit more of the keyboard and
things like that
okay
so um you've got different machine modes
auto interrupt single optional optional
stop and manual so i'm gonna go into
manual mode
and it tells me the control power is off
pretty straightforward press power on
and it tells me servo power is off press
start cycle to enable servo drives
all right power's on
my
machine is still dark though i do have
lighting so i'm just going to press the
little light
button here on my pendant it takes a bow
yep hold it for three four five seconds
lights on in the machine
so the first thing we're gonna do is
we're gonna calibrate our machine
uh we do this every day
um let me just swing in here for a
second so you can see we were
parked
right
and so when i press the calibrate button
and i'll do that in just a second
let's show make it to where you guys can
see
what's happening
i think that
works okay
uh so calibrate machine button i pressed
it and it tells me press cycle start to
begin calibration
guys this is just homing right
z goes up x y goes to that back corner
and it gets itself
calibrated now one thing that it does it
does two calibrations it will calibrate
the
axes and then it's going to calibrate
the tool changer so you get to this
point and you're wondering what's going
on
it tells me on the screen now tool
magazine will calibrate press cycle
start and the cycle start button is
flashing at me so i press that button
and the
uh tool changer will calibrate
so that's basically it for that part
okay we're back at the control we've
done our
calibration you know takes what 30
seconds
uh at this point i i run a warm-up cycle
and what's really cool about this is
it's got a built-in warm-up cycle you
don't have to write anything in here um
i do two things when i do this warm-up
cycle i let it run and it steps through
but i also i turn the coolant on as well
it just lets it aerate and cycle through
and
helps kind of get thermal
stuff going as well
so let's close it up
we don't really have to if we're not
going to run the coolant but we'll close
the doors
press the warm-up machine button
you'll notice anytime there's a uh
program ready to run so cycle start it
flashes at you you do have to hold this
down for a second that is one uh slight
difference that i've noticed on this
versus other controls but it's not bad
so cycle start
it's going through its cycle at this
point i'm gonna turn the coolant on
[Music]
and
it's just i don't know it's worth
showing you guys but basically
this is my warm-up cycle right
it just goes back and forth
this thing's moving and it's going to
step through the different rpms up to
the 12 000 that i have
so
at this point
i will bring you back when our warm-up
cycle is done all right um
so i've got a piece of stock that i put
in
so our next step
on this
just go ahead and put this stock in now
guys this isn't how i'd normally hold it
i'd probably believe it or not since i
use these double vices all the time
you know i'd probably have it somewhere
like here right
um
works great
throw it in there
so let's give it a little tension
and this is not about work holding right
i'm
being very sloppy with this right now
guys i know
this is not about work holding
this is about process
so
right
get this guy tightened up
ready to go i'm not worried about it
all right so we've got our stock in
place next thing i would do is i would
call up tool 99 which is the
uh probe so let me
bring you over to the control so you can
see how some of this works okay we're
going a little uh into the uh shaky cam
right now
man glare is bad all right doing what i
can here but basically what we're gonna
do we're gonna go we're still in manual
right so that manual button we pressed
still a manual i'm gonna come up to tool
management
and
so you've got different ways to do this
you can
do a list of all your tools shows with
pockets they're in you can come into
your manual tools you know you can
scroll around things like that
but if you already know the number like
in this case i know
we're going to do tool 99 i come down to
the keypad type in 299 press enter
enter is really important on a herco
control when you type something in you
have to press enter for it to actually
be applied
so pretty easy move tool spindle
verify that it's zero
nothing's in there i'm gonna press cycle
start
all right we're ready to start probing
all right reposition the camera yet
again so i'm just using the
uh
the jog wheel
and i'm gonna get this thing close
to the center point because i'm gonna
use a rectangular uh probe on this
so i'm setting my zero position to be
to be uh
the center xyz center
or sorry at the top
x y
and then z z is top next is center
you guys get it
i can uh i can speak english i swear
okay
um so what i do
is i like to
use a known height
[Music]
um
and i like to get that thing
pretty close
so what i do is
i
i know that that parallel is 3 8 tall
so what i do is i bring this thing down
where it's
almost touching
and it's reflective
to your angle and you can't see it but
it's there and nice part about it is you
know if i touch it it's going to stop
it's not going to hurt anything
so i know i'm about 3 8 above right now
okay
um at this point i'm going to shift you
around we're going to go back to the
shaky cam i'm going to show you the
programming or show you the control part
of all of this okay we're back at the
control and at this point i'm going to
come down to the
touch panel here i'm going to press the
input button
input brings up a different screen so
each one of these uh these are the
different kinds of screen buttons you
can have up here right but input and
auto certain buttons here are going to
change what you see on the screen
and so
we load programs by using the program
manager you can do tool review you can
actually program right from here if
you're doing the conversational stuff i
don't do a whole lot of conversational
even though herco is known for his
conversational most of what i do is from
fusion now fusion 360.
so anyways part setup
we are going to look at work offsets so
you can see what our current work
offsets are
right um you notice that there is
you don't see a g54 or anything else
you got to keep in mind that there's
multiple
work coordinate systems in this control
so we're gonna go to work offsets and
now you'll see
g54 through whatever
um you can even uh with some of these
uh you know skew and all sorts of things
so we're gonna do part probing and
there's different parameters in here
uh part zero probe cycle so we're gonna
use uh there's the skew cycles as well
and then probe deflection offsets and
different settings you can do but we're
just gonna do it simple
we're gonna go to our probing cycles and
we're gonna select edge for now let's
pick up z first
so you notice we have different things
in here we'll go z
and it only has one direction it can
probe in in z so we press start probing
cycle
it tells you to press cycle start
come over here press the button
and it touches off the top of our part
now once it's done you'll see you'll get
a menu that says hey we're done
this is what we have you want to accept
this i'm going to say yes
okay
we are now set
that's in place if i exit out of here
and exit back
to our work offsets page you'll see now
that it's here so let's say
that i had probed it but our actual
um
our actual uh
part where coordinate system was going
to be 50 000 below that well i would
come in here and i can use the arrow
keys
sorry i know it's shaky cam these arrow
keys and numbers
but basically i could come in here and
tell it that we're actually going to go
50 thousands deeper than that so
that would be 136.
so i would type in 136 and i use the
delete key to get rid of the rest of
that remember enter
you have to press enter at that point
otherwise you don't get anything
so that would be fifty thou below i'm
not gonna do that i'm gonna go back exit
um oh actually no let's let's look at
that so
see how it says 21 uh 136 one
okay so that's our machine coordinate if
we look over here
you know it's telling us right now that
this is how far above it we are and our
z is at 13 because that's got our
offset for
the tool now i'm gonna go back into that
part probing
we're gonna do part zero edge we're
still at z
we're going to run it again
and we're going to watch what happens on
this screen now
so
on the dro side of things it's there it
tells me that i'm 50 thou off
right there is that 50 thou that i
manually put in
when i say yes
you'll see that it just changed and
automatically updated
pretty straightforward all machines do
this this is not
special
you guys got this if you want to learn
how to use the herco it is pretty easy
to do
okay so we are doing rectangular solid
outside we have to tell it how big it is
now i measured this part the stock to be
nine inches by four inches
uh by one inch tall right so probing
length if we typed in nine inches it
would try to go down right at nine
inches that's not any clearance so let's
tell this that we want it to go 10 and a
half in x enter
right we'll do five and a half inches in
y
now we're at
383 above
above the part right now
and i i want to come down
a half an inch from that so we're gonna
say minus point
eight eight
four
right
so because this three eighty three seven
is what it read so 80 minus 884 from
where i'm at right now so that's not
based on the z height that's based on
where the probe is right now
we press start
bring us back over here and when i press
cycle start
it's going to go through and do a very
familiar probing cycle that you guys
have seen
i'm sure
many many times on different
channels
so we're picking up our x first
[Music]
now the default on this i think you can
be
on your sizes
um if it's expecting to be at a certain
size
i
it's
i want to say it's like 10 millimeters
you can be off
on this and also your tool setter as
well
all right
it's got that we come back to our screen
you'll see it tells us where everything
is
and it tells me that i was actually
8.924
in length and i'm about four tenths
under in y
so yes
and there we are
our work coordinate system is now set it
tells me x y zero is there
uh and our z height is all set at this
point exit
and you don't really have to completely
exit out because i want to clear this
tool out of the spindle i don't want it
sitting here with the battery going so i
go back to that manual button
tool management and i can just press
clear tool and spindle
tells me to press cycle start
let's put this bad boy away
and with that we have completed
we have now completed our probing
lesson
our next uh
our next task in this is actually to do
some tool setup
um
actually let's go back in here for a
second so we can look at what's already
in the machine and
there's a page up page down buttons you
can do arrows as well but this shows
everything that's in my machine right
now
let's take a look at tool 15.
so i select the tool move tool spindle
it's verifying that it's the spindle is
empty it is empty i press the button
we get a tool change now one thing i
like about this side load
typically it's gonna
it'll preload the tool and have it ready
to go
so it's in this next station when you're
just randomly grabbing well you know
it's a little slow
well it's not terribly slow i just got
really spoiled on other machines that
were like
one second ship to chip but
anyways
uh let's go back
so we're taking a look here's our tool
we'll do tool setup
and you'll notice we give it a tool
number
there's different kinds of tools and
notice contextually it changes as you
click you know select something it
changes
and
you can plug a mouse into this by the
way guys and i don't know if i didn't
show this to you but there is a keyboard
and it's got a little fall mouse and
stuff like that so there is a lot more
in here
but anyways to drill
that's the size
tool cal length it's telling me that
it's 7.2023
and p means that it's probed
um
but uh
let's say that i didn't know what it was
what would i do or i've just put a new
tool in
here for instance so i'm gonna come in
here to more i'm gonna tool probing and
the first thing when you come in here
it's not gonna have anything in here
right you have to tell it something so
the first thing you have to do is what
kind of cycle am i doing in this case
i'm doing length so just length no
problem
um most of the stuff i don't have to
worry about
the only big thing here is
i this length and so
i
have something in here but let's say i
just replaced the drill i got dull i
swapped the drill out and i'm gonna make
a change here so i'm gonna measure
i and you do it from when you're taking
your measurement
actually
i'll show you guys how i do this
sorry about the uh
set up here okay
i literally i grab my tape measure i
come in here to the
to the uh
tool holder can you guys see
should be just high enough
and i'm just getting a close you know
estimate here i'm gonna say
like seven and a quarter
right
so i i measured it at seven and a
quarter
so i'm going to type in seven point
whoops sorry seven 7.25
and remember enter notice the p went
away
right it's measured you have to be about
within 10 millimeters right well 10
millimeters is you know that's a pretty
pretty wide
number on this so you just have to be
close
it doesn't have to be perfect
uh you notice you can do sister tools
and all kinds of things i i don't do
that uh you can tell it to
uh be part of multi-tool probing so if
you have a job where you want it to just
you know
every time that you run this job you're
going to do a multi-tool probe where you
just press the button and it sets all of
your tools for you you can do that
it is kind of nice and i do that for
certain jobs
so
at this point sorry let's probe current
tool now
so i press probe current tool
we come over here
and
big surprise it moves over rapids to
where it's pretty close
comes down and touches off
you guys have seen this before i'm sure
all right
we are set
and
oh look at that that's two tenths
i think it was
203 something i forget what it was but
it came up a little different
so cool i'm going to press enter just to
be you know careful about stuff like
that but i mean that's really it such
tools get your tools ready to go you're
ready for the next step which is to load
your program all right out of habit i
clear the tool out of the spindle and i
exit out of here but i'm gonna go down
now to that input button again right
input
and remember i said we go to program
manager to manage our files these are
all programs that are already loaded up
in this machine
you can
i use usb i have network
setup here you can save files directly
to the hard drive one thing to note
about herco's control
is it does
you should always pull files into the
control you don't want to
try and push a file from your computer
into the machine it does not like that
at all file permissions and things like
that it doesn't work well
i'm gonna open
and you can see this is all my my actual
network stuff right so
yeah please don't um do anything crazy
and
i was just working on this thing and
uh
let me think
this guy here
there it is i'm going to load it and it
says hey it was already loaded you sure
you want to do this i'm just going to
say yes
now one thing is it's here in the list
and it's highlighted so the the file
that's highlighted is the one that
you're going to be working with
if i say
um
at this point if i just press the enter
key it goes into an editor
right and i can take a look at this file
and figure out what it's doing
so it's going to use
tool three which is just flat end middle
see 2014
right pretty straightforward i can
scroll down
not a whole lot going on on this one
right
so
i forget what i was doing on on this
particular one but that's okay we'll
work with it we'll exit
and at this point we are ready to go
so
i will press the auto button in the
machine mode down at the bottom we'll
press the i don't know i guess you guys
might want to see it but press the auto
button
and we get a new setup
now
one of the things that i love about this
control is the dry run button
right dry run lets you do just that test
it how high do we want to go above z
i'm going to say one inch
press enter at which point it's ready to
run
now i'm going to stop this and go back
to that auto because the first thing i
want to do is just check for errors
is will this thing actually even run
it says it'll run okay again i'm not
even certain what this program is but
since i know that we're going to be an
inch above
i'm not too worried about it we're okay
so let's run it i'm going to turn my my
rapids down though to about 50
[Music]
okay
i'm going to press run
looks like start it prompts me to verify
that the spindle is empty
and i've got my finger over the feed
hold button
well let's not ruin things
okay
i paused it
i'm looking at my
screen here and it's telling me that
i've got about 300 to go
yeah that should be okay
i'll let it go down
okay
so all we were doing is a contour pass
on this
so you can see that it's coming through
and running this part now what's nice is
i'm going to press that feed hold again
and i'm going to get a 1 2 3 block out
and i'm going to verify that hey
that's that's right okay good just
barely fit under there
perfect
things are working to plan but you can
also let it run through and it's gonna
run through its whole program and you
can make sure that yes it's actually
where you expected it to be
you didn't have a contour selected on
the wrong side especially on a chamfer
right where you're you know you're
supposed to be doing a five thousand
chamfer and you're on the wrong side of
the contour and you're doing a you know
three hundred thousand
right
so this is obviously for a slightly
longer part
but uh yeah you guys get the idea
and so i'm just going to go ahead and
show you one other neat feature about
this while we're at it we're in the dry
run but
this is really cool and this is one of
those unique features that i was talking
about earlier
interrupt button i love this button
watch what happens when i press
interrupt
it stops
it pauses i can then if i need to
i can uh
i can jog the part towards me i can do a
measurement whatever else when i'm done
i come back to auto
tells me to press cycle start again we
come back here when i press cycle start
it picks up where it left off
i mean how cool is that
i didn't have to do anything special
it'll fire up the spindle and everything
we're in dry run so it's not running any
of the other stuff but
i mean to me
that is one of the coolest features of
the control and i i use it all the time
right
especially
if i'm trying to make sure if i'm you
know
if i'm concerned about chip build up or
whatever else i can just come in i can
pause it real quick blow it off you know
look at the the tool make sure the tool
doesn't have a
chip you know stuck to it or something
like that
once i'm satisfied
take it right back off where it left off
all right i'm gonna go ahead and just
stop this
because it's not doing us any good
and your pop quiz on this one is can you
remember
i showed you how to do this what did i
just do to clear the tool in the spindle
give you five seconds to think about it
right i pressed manual and i went to the
tools and i pressed the clear tool in
spindle
button
pretty straightforward huh
all right that's it
all right there is a lot more that we
could go into and go in depth on the
control itself but the basics here
right the important part and what
what i was asked to show is
once you've got your program out of
fusion what do you do with it how does
it work in the herco and
that's what we did
we just just to recap we walked through
turning the machine on initializing the
machine
we did a warm-up cycle we
i
added a
work coordinate system so we did probing
we
checked on tools and made sure our tools
were right you know adding a tool is the
same process by the way you just type
something in new and you're adding it in
new
we did tool probing the tool detection
uh we loaded a file
closing is the same way by the way guys
you go to that same program manager so
we loaded a file we did a dry run to
test everything out the only other thing
that you could do oh we checked for
errors you can even do simulation things
like that i didn't show that in this but
check for errors and then lastly
the last step really is just to run that
program and let it go
so guys it's not complicated you can do
this
um if you like this kind of video let me
know i'll make more of them i just need
the feedback anyways thanks for watching
thanks for subscribing and i'll see you
again real soon